1700多家公司我要怎麼看
我才找得到當沖的標地
盤中設定這些條件
就會多頭回後買上漲
又可以進
又可以進了
你又沖到漲坪板
你說怎麼可能
你會賣到漲坪
你去試一試
你一定會經常賣到漲坪
所以你買十張
讓我這一沖今天最了解
兩萬四
老師今天要提供五種日線的看法
抓出比較容易做的當沖股的類型
成功最高的這個
就是這個是旗漲
洗澡的第一根紅K棒
所以這種圖形是非常重要
你又看又是這個圖
就覺得中了
這個有5%
這個大概有半個月
怎麼那麼過癮
朱老師
你現在超紅
那是因為你的
你的原因
你看我們的衣服
對
叫做紅配綠 一定轉
不能講後面那個
但是有一些鐵粉
他對我上次跟你講的一句話
他有一點意見 真的喔
對 因為我就說
因為你教我一直看那個可以棒
我說我真的很希望
就把你綁在我桌子旁邊
這樣我要下單的時候
就可以告訴我怎麼做
但是有不同的解讀
其實粉絲我可以跟你講
你把我上課的好好學好
你先把這個學好
就不必綁我了
因為你自己就會做
而且你會被別人綁
不是學好的話
就像是朱老師上升
我自己就可以
對啊
但是很多人就講說
他要綁你也有人要綁我
當然 一定的
綁我他可能就沒辦法下單了
不
會不會有老亂
會分心
今天的理財大人秀
大家最期待的標古在線等
我們上一集教什麼呢
因為我們上次趙華有講過
其實趙華比較不喜歡教當沖有沒有
但是因為是朱家宏朱老師
朱老師的當沖
充滿了提醒丁寧跟方法
但是非常多人留言囉
就是說
可是台股有1700多家公司
我要怎麼在一開盤
1700多家公司我要怎麼看
我才找得到當沖的標的
所以趙華今天再度破例
因為是朱家宏朱老師
他來告訴你
你如何在前一天
或是前幾天
你就可以先做功課
篩出你適合做當沖的標的
這很重要
1700多檔
你要怎麼篩到
聚集你可以做當沖的標的
這一集一樣30遍起跳
好不好
我們先來看
想玩沖沖樂要看天觀浪
會不會太難了
對
看天觀浪
我們現在講做當沖
其實做股票也一樣
你要先把股票選好了
對啊 如果你選的股票不好
他也不會漲 甚至也還會跌
可是好難選喔
畫一盤
所以我們做當沖
第一個觀念
因為每天的盤不一樣
其實各位今天如果你去看
昨天每一股是不是大漲
對 那今天你就會發現
哎呦 開盤都會漲
最反的就是前一天大跌
前一天再大漲
對
所以因為我們做當沖
是做當天的行情
所以你要對當天的行情的好壞
要先判別
那這個判別去參考兩個東西
因為我們大盤是9點開盤
對不對 那我們做股票當中
9點開盤
那9點之前我們先看每股昨天
因為早上每股收盤
所以這個在我們早上9點之前
要做完這些功課
其實要更早吧
9點看不完
其實我們前兩集有講
你每天早上不要睡懶覺
你不要睡到10點再起床
那個蔥已經抽完了
浪已經沒有了
6 7點我就要起來看看
你大概7點鐘 8點鐘
就開始準備
準備先看美股的漲跌
好
如果美股大漲
那今天我們應該
大概都開紅盤了
都會漲
那另外要看一個韓國
韓國啊
那這個很多投資人
不太瞭解
對 我不是看鹿谷嗎
為什麼要看韓國啊
那因為我們跟韓國
聯動性比較密切
產業結構
產業結構 競爭都很密切
那韓國對我們有什麼影響
為什麼要看它
因為韓國8點開盤
比我們早一個小時
他比我們早
所以可以去看
例如今天各位就馬上回去檢查一下
今天韓國早上是不是開高盤
對
韓國開高盤我們就會開高盤
那韓國如果像今天早上9點對不對
8點55你去看韓國
韓國大概漲0.60 0.7%
所以我們今天大盤一開就70點
就反而跟著韓國的那個幅度帶走
不但是開盤走盤中也會
如果韓國一直殺下來
我們就會拉下來
我們盤中就會被拉
所以這個去觀察
那我們在盤前
如果你去判斷
美股也很好
韓國也很好
所以今天我們選股票
等一下會講
你會選兩隻多兩隻空
明天可以做空的可以做多的
那如果今天大盤是漲的
做多當然比較有利
對不對
那如果大盤像前天美股大跌
那我們都是綠色的
所以你去做空比較有利
這個就是盤前先新有個樹
今天大盤是漲還是跌
好 因為前一天美股的話
不管是東令或下令
早上四五點收盤
韓股八點提早開盤
有兩個領頭羊在告訴你怎麼走
告訴我們今天大概的航情
不過這有先說明
美股跟我們的聯動
比較沒有這麼密切
那只有什麼時候要注意
就大漲大跌
這個稻穹跌兩趴或漲兩趴
那這時候我們的台股就會受影響
那一般正常的話
你就看韓國就可以了
看韓國就可以了
也可以決定他開盤
開高還是開低
那開盤開高開低
跟你選的當充的標的有關
什麼有關就上一級
開高紅的 開高黑的
就是強弱弱
不要忘了
對 我這次要做多
那今天韓國開高
那你就去看怎麼開
如果他開高是紅的
你就準備做多了
開高走高
那我們盤前做完功課之後
要準備選股了
那大家比較
剛才趙華爺講比較困擾的
要怎麼選1000多檔股票
那其實我們選股票做當沖
因為我們後面今天特別會告訴大家
你選哪些圖形
那這些圖形如果你懂了
那你就在這裡面去找
你就會找到
那第一個當然就是
我們趨勢要很明顯
就是前一天特別報價的強勢股
等於說他有那種很強勢的上漲的
不是平平溫溫的
因為你要做多
股票一定要強
而且我們要做當充
當充不強烈 充不到錢
你也不會賠
但是你充不到
又很無聊
對 就好像我們選股要選標股
是一樣的道理
那如果你要做空
你在弱事股裡面去看
而且他要特別弱的那一種
特別弱的
那我在這邊先講這一個
那強勢股裡面就是
漲幅前100名
然後這邊寫強勢谷
所以等於老師的第一招
先找到強勢谷
強勢谷
對 不是超強勢就超弱勢
所以現在有一個叫做
掌幅前100名
那所有的看盤軟體都有
然後你在哪家眷商開戶
然後你就用它這個軟體
排名都有 甚至有些網站也有
也有
你收盤以後去看一下
因為你是要找明天的標的
所以你收盤就看哪些是強勢谷
排名排出來
前100名就好了啦
對 那這些強勢骨只有一百檔嗎
你就把圖點一點
那點一點就看符不符合我們後面講的
如果符合你就可以挑下來
但老師這邊有講
量小於500張就不要它了
還可以再刪掉一些
有一些可能量沒有到500張
沒有 軟體已經給你刪了
對 軟體已經把我刪了
已經設定好了
所以騎跑出來不會一百檔
更少
所以你大概就看這個強勢骨了
那第二個當然你就是看
弱勢股你就選
這個是弱勢股
反過來弱勢股一樣是跌幅嘛
跌幅前100名的
那你就看
另外你也注意一下
昨天有放量的
有放量的
那我們講說放量的股票
當然就比較容易漲
也比較容易跌
所以你再放量
那如果你這樣子
把放量的股又跟強勢弱勢股
去重疊一下
你就會發現
他又在強勢股他又放量
那是不是這支股票就更好
更容易抓到
好 那我們訪念
老師我們回到這一張
這邊有講對不對
這個是趨勢要明顯
趨勢你要抓多跟空
量要放大
然後再來當然這支股票
波動要大
波動要大我要怎麼知道呢
你選出來了以後
你就看他的前面的慣性
一個股票都有慣性
比如說我今天選他要做明天
你就看他前面
他前面如果每次一漲就連三火
那是不是這支股票今天漲
明天還容易漲
對
對 這個就是波動
好
或者我做空
他一疊就是黑黑黑黑
那我們選這種股票比較容易做
老師 那這個有像剛剛那種看盤軟體可以看
還是這就要手動自己一檔一檔看了
沒有 你在選股的時候
反正這邊已經縮小了選股的範圍
選出來後我們就觀察他的冠軍
就觀察他的冠軍
那可能你這邊選了五支
對
那你就一看
來一支的慣性最好
波動最大
不然就漲停
要不然就跌停
這邊已經聚焦了啦
所以不會那麼多
只要看了
我們就一擋一擋看一下
再看它的這個波動
那當然存焦量最好大一點
那我上一集有講
你們練習的時候買一張
先把信心練好
那以後你不會買一張的
因為你不可能要賺那個
五百塊一千塊
我們有講嘛
你買個十張就一萬嘛
但是你那時候一定要練好
所以你的這個要成交量來打贏
以後我變大戶了
一次100張 200張
2 300張你就出不了
買成400張大戶了是不是
沒錯 沒錯
總有一天
那當然不要忘
你的停損跟停力
紀律實在太重要
停損是不會大賠
但停力如果你做不好
你也賺不到
因為漲上去你不賣
隔天或者是交割的法有問題
當天就會下來
對 他到一個點
老師有教我們嗎
他可能就轉絡轉絡轉絡轉絡
對 乾賣的時候你要賣掉
這樣子把它做好
這四個方式
四個方式 四個方式把它注意好
然後就注意開盤了
就注意盤中的紀律
好 盤中的紀律
這邊趙華也要叮嚀一些網友
因為很多人來留言是很肯定我們
但是也有人說
這樣好像騙人啦
這樣好像是有風險
我們上一集真的仔細看
風險是我們提醒最多的
你要做當中你要是高手 不是新手
這件事你千萬要記起來
所以也有很多人
我講實話啦
有些人是不適合做當中
是
你就乖乖的做不飄
不是你就報個三五天
因為當中第一個你要看盤
沒錯
如果你心事很忙
今天要想這個事 想那個事
你要做當中
怎麼可能做得好啊 不可能嘛
一下要接個電話
一下老闆找我
對 你不可能當沖
所以你自己心裡知道
你這樣子不可能做得好
那第二個當然你反應要很快
他不對 你要趕快跑
對
對了 賺到你也要趕快跑
所以如果那個反應比較遲鈍的
想了個半天
像那個漁成啊
漁成 對 不要做當沖
想了個半天才決定的
不是說你不太適合啦
當然你說我一定要練
當可以 你就磨嘛
模糊到適合
所以自己還是要衡量
沒關係 我們還是佛心繼續教
對
另外還有一種方法就是
你昨天很忙 沒有時間選股
可是你今天盤中
也有機會找稻骨票
因為我們的軟體在盤中
有一個設定條件的選股
你如果條件設定好
它就會跳出來
開盤它就會開始跳
那我們一般大概設這四個條件
老師 這還是可以先從
例如說盤前我們做好的功課
裡面如果再符合這個條件
可能就更好對不對
這個是盤中
盤中開盤後又跳出這樣的條件
昨天你沒有選到這支股票
所以沒選到也可以利用這一個
也可以在盤中找到
找到當充的標的
那你把盤中離給他條件
這支股票如果今天有爆亮
然後開盤是開高的
第一個設定他是爆亮的
開高的
開高強勢
然後一分鐘就有在拉的
一分鐘內連續上漲兩趴以上
那表示有人在買了
主力表態
對 然後連續三筆都是外盤
外盤等一下老師在幫我們講解清楚
講到外盤
如果符合這個條件
他在盤中就會跳出來
9點以後他就跳
那這時候你就去看
你就去點他的圖
那這個圖如果符合我們後面講的
當充的條件
那你就可以在盤中
就找到一支做當充的
所以朱老師剛剛前面講的是
盤前可以做功課
盤前先選好的
那盤前做功課來不及的人
盤中設定這些條件
而且很多的下單PP是可以設定的
都有
那你就去
所以我剛剛有講
做當中技術分析要很強
所以要剛剛講功力要很強
對 你技術分析要很強
也就是說你大概只有五秒鐘可以看
因為你點出來就看
然後你大概要決定了
好 那你可以觀察日K圖
有沒有今天要上漲的各部
那看五分K走勢決定
第二步是觀察日K圖
也就是你看到這張
這條這個狼骨票
你就看他日K
觀察日K
日K又符合今天要上漲
那剛好你又沒有注意
現在你發現
然後你就看五分K
最後看五分K
這個等一下一個一個
我們都會慢慢交
然後你就進到五分K了
那這個就是我們
剛才設了條件
選股的條件
剛才我們有設四個條件
什麼爆大量啦
開高強勢
一分鐘連續上漲2%嘛
對不對
這些條件
這個多目不忘
多目不忘
要學習力要強啊
你可以做當中
你太厲害了
好 那這邊就會告訴你嘛
這支股票跳出來
因為股價連續上漲
是
這個一分鐘拉了2%
對
然後或者有爆量
是
你就會去看
然後看了以後
也許這裡面就有你熟悉的股票
前幾天很強
然後每一掌
今天怎麼又強了
因為今天他跑出來了
你又很熟
那你今天趕快點他的圖
是不是今天啟攻
如果他今天起掌
你就趕快看五分K
五分K就符合我們教的
不要忘了
五分K要開高紅K
那你就可以做了
五分K就是上一集
大家就熟悉
有強強 強弱弱 弱弱弱
有一點小複雜要學起來
開盤釋法很重要
對 開盤釋法
不要誤會以為說
股票開盤就跑進去了
結果一開始可以
不要賠錢 先不要賠到
好不好
這就是盤中選股
盤中選股 一個方法
不過聽起來盤中選股
他自己對股票要有一定的認識
還是要很熟
不然跳出來你都沒看過
也不知道選哪一檔
對 所以要看圖
所有的股票以我來講就是靠圖
如果你把圖拉掉
我也這邊瞎子一樣
我也不知道能不能做
我也不曉得
所以按照剛剛老師教的一個SOP
其實我們就可以找出案例
真的就是照這樣子選出來
對
好 我們來找個案例好不好
我們選圖裡面有個一星二陽
一星二陽 什麼意思
等一下我們有五個圖
讓大家練習
去找這種圖
一星二陽就是我很強
然後我就留了一個變盤線
這個變盤線第二天就有兩個可能
一個就是回答
一個就是再長
如果他第二天繼續往上漲的話
那他就走一星兩個洋
兩個紅K
那這邊也有一個
你看這個是不是紅K
是
那第二天是星
對
那你說這個紅K
我第二天可不可以當沖
第二天可不可以當沖
看起來可以啊
收盤已經前一天了
其實第二天有高點
所以你當沖的人在高點是賣掉了
所以你不要看收盤
你收盤說你看都沒有賺到錢
那是你在盤中已經跑了
就是要看五分 k
五分 k 下來沒走
所以你仔細看這個 k 線
是不是開高
是不是拉高
所以你當中衝到了
你有衝到
所以這是我們後面選讀的一個
kk 配紅 k
明天就可以衝
這個衝完了
那這是新
那第二天又來了
這個一星二陽
所以你又衝到了
一星二陽
所以一星二陽
現在我們又看到了
又看到一星了
那明天又有機會衝
然後你開盤就進嗎
沒有 我大家看第一跟9.5分的不可以啊
所以你開盤不能進喔
導致的陷阱挺多的
他是開低的
所以你不能進喔
但是他如果開低走高
多頭回後買上漲
你又可以進了
你又衝到漲停板
開低不要貿然進啦 對不對
所以一支好股票你把它鎖住喔
你看
這裡你衝一次
衝兩次
衝三次
你可以衝三次
可以重三次
做三趟
對 可以做三趟
所以這個叫一行而養
好 我們在日線選好了
因為我昨天就看好了
如果他今天的五分K開得好
我就可以做
開得不好我就再等
再等
那我們就來看
這個大家也可以回去複習那個K棒
他就是變盤線
變盤線並不代表會開高
或開第一個天
都有可能
他又有變 可能不變
那我們來看第二天的五分K
第一個五分K
這是5分K喔 這張圖是5分K
第一根5分K喔 我們都有講
你要根據昨天的趨勢
我們那個上一集
大家一定要看100遍
你要點100個讚
一個人只能一個讚啦
要找100個人來點讚
因為我剛才講吧
因為你5分K一定要速度快
所以你要很熟練
你還沒有開你就先看
因為你昨天已經準備好了嘛
所以你今天早上8點半就先看
他昨天怎麼走
昨天其實這個叫均線糾結
就是要把它擋住囉
昨天這個叫均線糾結
然後第一個我們講開低嘛
這是黑的黑黑不能買
但是他沒有破低點
沒有破前低
對 然後再來
回後買上漲
所以這跟紅K很標準
如果我們把它當作日線看
這也是經常
反正突破均線糾結
對 均線的話還通通排列成期
沒錯 你就買了
所以這段你買的話大概29塊4
也就是快收盤嘛
五分鐘你決定好快收盤
它又是進場位置你就進場
那我們在上一個節目也有講
進場以後這支股票如果很強
漲停板就要賣
對 漲停板已經是最大獲利極限
對 所以事後我講
我賣在漲停板你一定不相信
你說怎麼可能你會賣到漲停板
對 因為這圖跑出來
你說你賣在最高點我也會花
其實我在這裡漲的時候
漲停板那個價目已經設好了
其實上市老師有講
你就設漲停板一定要賣出
所以盤中一輛漲停板你就敲
你就把它敲出去
你去試一試
你一定會經常賣到漲停板
那為什麼
怎麼那麼過癮
我們去看這張圖
因為我們上次節目也有舉例
這張圖就告訴你
這個時候開低
走高 是
然後這個地方開低走高
說紅KL我們進了
你就會至少你會先做到這裡
因為這條叫壓力線
壓力線 好
你至少會先長到這
那你長到這大概有兩趴了
老師壓力線還沒有交
還沒有 那個要到
沒關係 我們之後的課程
會安排什麼叫壓力線
什麼叫支撐線
要到高級班裡面去
好 高級班 好
高級班
那壓力線你這個兩趴
他已經到了嘛
我們講做當中兩趴嘛
所以你就開始準備囉
你要準備獲利
那你很幸運
這支股票的壓力就過了
過壓力了
過壓力就準備漲停了
你就準備他漲停了
過了壓力會回測
他會回來
但這個不能破
不能破壓力線
只要他不破
再來你就準備敲了
漲停滿就敲
那第二個我們在這個地方做了
你就去看盤中
我剛才照華講什麼叫做外盤
什麼叫類盤
類盤 對
你就看什麼叫外盤
就是在這個地方
掛賣的成交
賣的會比買的要價錢高
那就是外盤
他為什麼會外盤成交
因為買的人買不到
所以提高價錢
提高價錢去買
他去提高價錢買
那每個人都提高
提到最後就到漲停買
對不對
你追不到我們就漲停買買
你就一定買到嘛
所以漲停買有人在成交
對
有人買啊 對不對
那如果大家都在外盤買
像這一支股票64%都是外盤成交
外盤成交就是他賣出的價格
其實比大家想買的價格是高的
那沒辦法囉 只好去買囉
就追高嘛
大部分的人都願意追高
去把他賣進來
所以這股票今天很強
那這支股票能不能夠今天做到
其實還有一個就成交量跟爆量
當然量更重要
因為沒有量金那種會攻
老師 因為爆大量
有時候大家會覺得是警訊
可是在當充爆大量跟做長線波段爆大量是不一樣的意義對不對
其實當充爆大量是旗漲的地方
頭上爆亮也要走的
要走齁 旗漲爆亮OK的就充吧
因為我們早上要準備買嘛
那這時候就有亮
所以他今天容易讓你做到
你很容易成功
是
但是如果跑上去了 亮越來越大 那壓力就大了
如果到這裡 你看在這個地方
如果你開始到漲停板爆亮
那就不行 他就會開了
他就很容易打開
所以我們在盤中
你在加上這個觀察
我講說我們做
即使做5分K成功率要高
你經常停損也不行
對不對
但是我有這些東西輔助
有開盤5分K 有旋鼓調界
有盤中的成交量
跟盤中的支撐壓力
即使做當中
你成功率也很高的
也是很容易做
上次有講大概7、8成功率
對
那這樣子我們就知道
為什麼連加這支股票
從日線去選
從五分可以去看
從量
然後在盤中的自身壓力去看
自身壓力以後再交
然後還包括我看到他放量
然後外盤的買氣很濃
所以剛剛這一支股票
你去做的話
你當天的獲利
那我們在上集有跟大家特別講
你做當中也要有一個
有一個固定的金額
有 上次有說
有特別交代
先算出你每天可以
你承擔的賠损
對 虧損金的
如果你賠兩趴
你要賠6千塊
有沒有人接受 對不對
如果你能接受
我30萬
所以這個我買10張
因為你30塊嘛
是
很標準吧
沒錯
所以你買10張
那我這一充
今天是2萬4
2萬4 日淨萬金
對
這樣就很標準
就是SOP
很標準的作業
所以你都先做好準備
準備盤中
要買幾張
你都已經知道
不會臨時去想
對
已經先想好了
所以這個紅K十張
是
當沖裡面幾乎
不太有機會讓你加碼
因為他一拉就沒了
就拉上去了
你就要獲利了解
或停留出場
兩件事情要決定了
就不要貪心
當沖千萬不能當貪心
然後上次我們有講一些
5分K的開盤的戰法
就剛剛講的強強強弱那些的
但是如果是事前做功課
事實上老師今天要提供5張
5種日線的看法
抓出比較容易做的
當沖鼓的類型
對
我們講當沖要簡化
因為速度越快你就越不能複雜
那你複雜根本來不及
不像股票
你可以選一個禮拜以後再做都可以
或者等他
等啊 等他營收出來啊
等他什麼有很多的原因
當沖因為第一個盤中的獲利不會很高
我們有講兩趴以上
對不對
第二個就是因為你每天都要選股
因為你今天已經沖掉了
你明天沒有東西賣了
所以你晚上又要找東西來
所以你每天要找
那是不是這就很累
沒錯
所以不必
你就找這幾個圖
是
因為這幾個圖
第二天衝的機會最大
不是說別的不會啦
但是你
我剛剛講你搞得太複雜了
我覺得要聚焦
現在大家要就是說
我先知道這個破了
小小的裡面有什麼
你就找這幾個圖不就簡單多了
所以當衝也把它簡化
是
那我們今天介紹五個圖
這五個圖
如果你今天在這個收盤以後有看到
第一張圖
第一張我們叫做K線橫盤
K線橫盤是不是
K線橫盤是技術分析的一個名詞
今天如果收盤
你找到一支股票是這樣的
什麼叫K線橫盤
有一根K線
然後就沒有突破 沒有跌破
它就在這根K線裡面
三天以上
要三天
一天 兩天 三天
這個已經四天了
你就可以守的
因為這個K線橫盤
五分K是什麼
五分K是盤子
好 他現在
這是日線
連四天他都在盤子
都在盤子 都在K線很盤
那如果今天的五分K
把這個四天都突破呢
那就很強
對啊
這個就會跑出一根長紅
但如果跌破呢
就長黑囉
對 所以因為這個在五分K
是一個四天的盤子
這個五分K盤了四天
請問今天如果突破
是不是很容易做到
跌破也很容易做到
OK 所以如果你找到四根橫盤的
明天準備兩個方向
那如果大盤明天早上是好的
大概應該往上的機率比較高
剛剛有講了嘛
盤前因為韓股都在漲了對不對
那如果今天韓國會就開很低
那這個盤今天就可能會下
就會下
所以這種旋股就是多空都有可能
沒有說一定做多
因為它往下五分K嘛 開低黑K嘛
又把這個盤枕疊破
你就做空
所以第一張圖就是在盤枕
橫盤裡面表態
對
而且我們事前做過功課
搞不好美股大漲 韓股大漲
可能就往上囉
但反之可能就下跌
好 第一張K線圖是這個
那機會就看第一個5分K
好 機會看上一期的5分K
對
好 我們看一個圖
好
這是日線選股
選明天要當充的
各位看這已經盤了多少天了
這很多天
可是後面每一天的開盤都沒有過
都沒有突破
所以你開盤要突破
所以這個地方開盤一突破
他當天就會漲
那其實這種股票
你今天做明天還有
因為今天是突破了
因為突破了
應該還要再一根對不對
所以明天還可以做
對不對
來
突破 明天還可以做
這很大段
這樣OK嗎
所以橫盤的突破
其實我們在做股票
這是進場位置
我們做股票多頭回後買上漲
這個橫盤突破也可以買
所以帶這個橫盤突破
我們還是要找突破點
因為它可能是五天
可能六天 可能十天
可能二十天
就是你今天要符合條件
開盤五分K 紅K
然後要往上走
你才可以進
總之看到它在橫盤就先列入
列入你的口袋名單
今天就有如果突破就有機會
那第二張圖呢
那第二張就是我們講的
下跌的時候看到紅K了
下盤下跌的黑K看到紅K
這也是日線對不對
那我們在日線選股嘛
選明天的當充
所以前天是黑K
然後再來
今天收盤是紅K
我就做明天
明天開高的5分K
去做當充
這個都一樣
但這個就只能做多囉
好 這個就只能做多嘛
這兩種都只能做多嘛
你不能做
沒有 因為今天是紅的啦
對 人家監視紅
然後開盤五分開又是紅
那個做多去了
所以這個是大量紅K
明天做多的
那我剛剛講你在收盤一百檔
對
如果有這個圖
你為什麼會在強速谷
你找到它
因為它今天很強
對
所以它今天會列在強速谷
是
你又看又是這個圖
就覺得中了 中了
中了嘛
對
對不對 你就把它挑出來
明天你就準備看五分開
是
好 那我們就舉個例子
也可以囉
你看每天都在疊
對你出現了
其實這邊很可怕第一大段對不對
那我來問為什麼明天你沒有做
因為第二天是開低的
所以你沒有做
這個沒有開高嘛
可是再來就開高了
所以這個你就可以做了
也就是說黑K有兩天都是紅K
那今天是開高了
你就可以開高走高
老師這邊對我來
如果連三天有點像盤整
也像K線很盤
對 也像K線很盤
所以你看這個是掌琴版喔
也就是說你今天開高走
我還又拉到漲停板
其實當沖有的時候
你經常會碰到漲停板
不過開高走高漲停板
我賺就不夠多
還不夠多
他要開一點點高漲停板
這個有5%啦
這個大概有半折啦
那這個第二天
其實第二天還有
但是沒辦法沖
因為他漲停
一開始就漲了
一開始就受阻
這就沒辦法了
好
沒問題 第二張圖
就是下跌之後後來隔天
它是一個大紅K的時候
第三張就是
第一檔留了一個大量長下引線
那這個本來就是一個紙疊訊號
對
我們如果技術分析有學過的
在下疊的第一檔大量長下引線
是一個紙疊
等於有人在收盤的時候
把他拉上來了
那當然明天就有機會了
如果他拉上來
不管你是空頭要反彈
還是多頭要再續長
那你明天都有可能出一根長紅
所以這個明天就來
這等於是雖然是黑K
可是在這邊的黑黑有人在收穫
對
有人在收穫
這叫低檔爆亮
如果在低檔又有爆亮
又有拉下影線
有人在買了
那我們就看第二天
買的人是不是第二天在公
如果第二天在公他就會開高
所以如果第二天開高
對
五分開是紅的
就應該去做多
沒錯
所以第二天向上做多
向下就不要做了
好 那我們今天看到這一根
開長下隱線
那第二天開高
這個也是
但第二天有沒有做
沒有嘛
所以你不會犯規嘛
你也不會說
老師 我選到這個
怎麼都賠錢
因為隔天不符合啊
對啊 你又沒有符合
所以一定要每個環節都要
都要注意到
都要符合到
你不能只抓一個你就跑進去了
所以你第二天沒有做嘛
所以你也不會賠 對不對
好 那這個呢 開高符合
所以你這個是有符合
你做一天 其實漲停喔
最後也是漲停
因為你的黑黑收藩在下面
所以你第二天是漲停版
又差不多抓到5%
我講2%以上都應該很高興
因為你當初每天2%就不得了
當初就設定是2%以上就好
2%是你的目標
好 我們再看
第四章圖
第四章是吞噬
吞噬
各位會問跟剛才前面第一張
有什麼區別
前面不是有個紅K嗎
對啊
那個紅K是要等第二天才能確認
好 我們可以來對比一下
因為大家可能會弄混
那個叫紙疊
剛剛這是第二張圖
這個叫紙疊
還沒有過高
所以這個一定是明天
明天才那個
紙疊而已
因為他沒有過高
不一樣的圖
明天你要開高
但是這個第四章不一樣囉
這個如果有大量又吞噬
這個已經反彈確認
那當然他又有大量又把KK高
所以明天容易有開高
那這個如果在多頭強勢股
還有第二天還有第三天
第一天第二天第三天
你還有第三天當充的機會
所以看到了這種大量長紅吞噬
多頭回檔嘛
所以你第二天要進
第二天要做
好 這看起來就很厲害了
對 所以如果你有看到
吞勢就是我紅K收盤
把黑K收盤過了
吃掉了 對 實體棒
紅K把黑K的實體棒吃掉了
這個叫吞勢
那第二天就按照紀律做
就進場 這個開一個小平盤
稍微開低喔 開低
我不能進場不是嗎
就可以進場的第二根
就是第二根他也紅K了對不對
其實你如果把這支股票
掉回去看5分K
2019應該還有
你去看5分K
這個開低
第一根是紅的
第一根是紅K吧
因為他開低走高
所以第一根5分K是紅的
就可以進場了
你又過了昨天的高點
所以你第一個5分K就進場了
那今天大概不只5%了
那這個我們在當中還有一個要
我今天要去做
我的壓力在這嘛
這有個季線
有個季線嘛
我這裡有一個
漲停板的空間
所以你做當沖就很容易
也就是說你不要選一個
我今天明天就
只有兩趴就預壓
那你就比較難做
還要搭配均線
所以中間有蠻多活用的空間
要搭配你上漲的空間
你有沒有這個空間
如果有就很容易
可能漲一兩趴就壓力的
那整轉不到
那你在盤子五分黑一上
就被打下來
你就會慌嘛
你就很容易賣掉
那當然這個就是要越來越精進
功力的集合
那我們先知道
那這個第二天就容易衝到
最後一張囉 第五張圖
其實我們剛才範例已經講了
就叫一星二陽
一星二陽來了
我們做多就叫一星二陽
那一星二陽我們剛有看到
在這邊坐 在這裡又有
對不對 上面又有一星二陽
那成功最高的是這個
成功最高的是這個
就是這個是旗掌
旗掌的第一根紅K棒
那第二天會休息
一個變盤線
它會休息
那第三天再開高它就再漲
再漲一根紅K棒
很多股票第二天都不漲的
它都會這樣子
然後就把你洗掉了
你就買錯了洗掉了
對 洗掉
那這個你就準備
第二天準備開高走高
做一行二亞
因為它在第一檔
所以這個變盤線不太容易變
可是你在高檔就容易變
他就容易往下邊
所以如果你找到一星二陽
又在旗掌這個位置
那明天是很高的
很高的成功的機率
做到的機率很高
所以這種圖形是非常重要
好 很重要
我們今天我們來看一下
這個是不是回後買上漲
這旗掌
第二天是星
一星二陽要特別注意
變盤線要在紅K上面
等等 變盤線要在紅K上面
好 剛剛沒講到
這代表強
好 變盤現在在紅K的上面
那第二天如果又是開高走高
就做多了
那這個就在起掌
所以他比較容易做
比較安全而且
那第二天一定要開高
千萬記得
不要說我又找到一星二陽了
結果第二天開盤又亂做
但你還是會失敗
所以五分K說起來是一個
蠻精密的工程
就是每一步每一步
你都要算得很好
對 條件全數符合才可以進場
沒錯沒錯
所以有人說當充很難
是有點難
是很難
就是因為你條件要很多
你這樣才容易做到
因為它短時間
這麼短時間你就要抓獲利
所以你沒有這麼多的條件
你很難做到
所以我希望這幾集
大家都要重複看
如果你想要做當充的話
沒錯
而且老師你這邊有一個沒有講是
他是可以做空
好 這個做空
做空喔
因為我們今天是以做多
五個做多為主
好
這個是做空好不好
因為我相信也是有很多朋友
真的很進階
因為趙華覺得做空又比做多
在人性上又難一些些
但是既然有做多的方法
一定就有做空的方法
所以做空的方法會在哪裡呢
會在我們的精英班
我們這邊先秀一下
這邊有一個當中的做空祕技
這個在精英班等一下會說
但是在菁英斑之前
趙華也要來謝謝
好久沒有謝謝
我可愛的粉絲們
我們來念一些留言好不好
因為以前已經都沒有念
這叫李玉賢
他說真的一聽就愛上朱老師了
以前都是愛上趙華
現在怎麼都愛上朱老師了
他說直接就加入了你的菁英斑
想要聽更多
然後這個 FTH
他說喜歡朱老師也喜歡趙華
謝謝你喔
預教娛樂
你說出我們節目的精髓了
學了很多 謝謝
好這個Peter他說
中心感謝朱老師跟李小姐
我很少人叫李小姐
和朱的單位讓我受益肥鹹
在骨骸裡看見了名燈
真的謝謝你們
哇 這些都是很真心的
因為我們都會告訴你
風險在哪裡 獲利在哪裡
不是說
就衝進去叫你一直買
然後覺得自己很厲害
絕對不是這樣
這是一個
真的是中心教學的節目
那今天非常感謝朱老師
當中的第二堂課
上一集教你怎麼看五分
可以這一集教你怎麼做盤前的功課
用日線挑出你最適合的當沖果
讓你來不及做也沒關係啦
盤中還會給你一些提示喔
可是你自己要知道
當沖是高手在做的
親手 小心
控制你的風險好不好
控制你的停損 停歷喔
希望每個人都能鼓海當沖
超快樂樂地衝大彩
Bye Bye囉
Bye Bye
字幕by索兰娅